HAVE MUCH MORE COMING UP.
MIKE, THANK YOU.
>> IF A TEACHER DOESN’T SHOW UP
YOU CAN’T OPEN THE CLASS.
IF A PARENT DOESN’T SEND THEIR
CHILD, THERE IS NO CHILD TO
EDUCATE.
AND THAT IS IN ALL DOABLE.
>> Sandra: THE GOVERNOR SAYING
IT WILL TAKE A JOINT EFFORT TO
GET SCHOOLS REOPENED.
TEACHERS ARE PUSHING BACK ON A
COMBINATION OF HOME AND IN
CLASSROOM LEARNING OVER SAFETY
CONCERNS.
LET’S BRING IN MAX ROSE.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
HE HAS TO ANSWER TO THE
TEACHERS SAYING WE DON’T FEEL
SAFE GOING BACK.
HOW DO YOU GET EVERYBODY ON
BOARD FOR THE SAME PLAN?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT WE TAKE
A STEP BACK AND SET A TABLE.
THIS MAYOR IS NOT ONLY THE
WORST MAYOR IN THE HISTORY OF
NEW YORK CITY, THE WORST MAYOR
IN THE HISTORY OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE NOT PUT OUT A PLAN
FOR OPENING THE SCHOOLS.
THEY PUT OUT A PRAYER.
AN OUTLINE AT BEST.
THERE ARE A FEW THINGS WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON HERE.
THE FIRST IS TESTING.
THERE IS NO REASON TO SAY THAT
EVERY SINGLE TEACHER IN NEW
YORK CITY SHOULD NOT BE TESTED
AT LEAST EVERY DAY, EVERY OTHER
DAY.
WE CAN RESOURCE THAT.
SECONDLY WE SHOULD BE PUSHING
FUNDS TO OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS ENOUGH
PPE AS WELL AS INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING.
BUT NOTHING CAN REPLACE
LEADERSHIP AND I DON’T BLAME
ANYONE TO INCLUDE TEACHERS,
PARENTS, FAMILIES, FOR NOT
HAVING FAITH IN THIS MAYOR
RIGHT NOW.
IT IS AN UTTER DISGRACE.
>> Sandra: OF COURSE, YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT HIS LEADERSHIP AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL HERE IN NEW
YORK CITY BUT THERE ARE SOME
WHO BELIEVE THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE A CLEAR PLAN FROM THE TOP AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THIS IS THE NATIONAL REVIEW ON
THE NEED FOR A NATIONAL PLAN TO
REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS.
HOW TRUMP CAN HELP.
IT WRITES WHILE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS NO POWER TO
REGULATE WHEN LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OPEN AND CLOSE A
NATIONAL STANDARD IS NEEDED.
IT SHOULD DEFINE OBJECTIVE
THRESHOLDS SO PARENTS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS NO WHEN IT’S
SAFE TO REMAIN OPEN AND CLOSED.
IT SHOULD BE SIMPLE,
PREDICTABLE AND MAKE CLEAR
SCHOOLS SHOULD OPEN EXCEPT
WHERE CORONAVIRUS BREAK-OUTS
ARE UNCONTROLLED.
HOW MUCH DIRECTIVE NEEDS TO
COME FROM THE TOP.
>> THERE IS A NOTION OF
NATIONAL PLAN VERSUS LOCAL PLAN.
IT HAS BEEN POLITICIZED.
I COULD SEE HOW THERE COULD BE
A NATIONAL CDC STANDARD WHEN A
SCHOOL CAN BE OPENED BUT WE
HAVE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CITIES AND STATES.
IT IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I’M TALKING ABOUT THE FAILED
LEADERSHIP OF THE MAYOR OF NEW
YORK CITY.
BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID,
THOUGH, AT THIS POINT WE ALSO
HAVE TO NOTE HERE THAT THERE IS
NOT REALLY ANY CAPACITY TO DO
ANYTHING IF WE DON’T HAVE
FEDERAL RESOURCING OF CRITICAL
SUPPLIES.
IT IS ONLY THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT CAN GET US ENOUGH SWABS,
THAT CAN GET US ENOUGH MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND ENOUGH LAB
TESTING PROCEDURES SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY GET THIS DONE FOR
OUR SCHOOLS.
A COMBINATION.
WE’LL COME TOGETHER.
>> Sandra: YOU WANT A LOT OF
THE DECISIONS ON OPENING THE
SCHOOLS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT
ASKING FOR ALL THE NECESSARY
SUPPLIES TO COME AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
I WANT TO PUT UP ON THE SCREEN
SOME OF THE MAJOR DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE ALREADY ANNOUNCED
THEIR REOPENING PLANS OR
CLOSING PLANS.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
OPENING FOR ONLINE ONLY,
CHICAGO, SAN FRANCISCO, LOS
ANGELES, SAN DIEGO.
NO IN-PERSON LEARNING WHEN
SCHOOLS OPEN IN THE FALL.
THEN YOU’VE GOT SOME WHO HAVE
DELAYED OR ARE CONSIDERING
DELAYING THEIR OPEN.
HOUSTON, ATLANTA, AND OTHERS.
THERE ARE ALL -- THIS IS THE
LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY WE HAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, IF YOU COULD
RESPOND TO WHAT THIS CARE.COM
HAS PUT OUT THERE A SURVEY
TALKING ABOUT THE LACK OF
IN-PERSON TEACHING HAVE A
DRAMATIC IMPACT ON WORKING
PARENTS.
IT COINCIDES WITH A REPORT WE
GOT FROM GOLDMAN SACHS EARLIER
IN THE WEEK THAT SAID MANY
PARENTS MAY HAVE TO STOP
WORKING ALL TOGETHER IF THEIR
KIDS AREN’T BACK IN SCHOOL OR
THEY’RE IN THIS HYBRID MODEL
WHERE THEY GO SOME DAYS AND
THEY DON’T GO SOME DAYS.
HOW DIFFICULT IS THAT GOING TO
BE FOR PARENTS TO MANAGE?
>> INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT,
INCREDIBLY.
THIS IS AN ECOSYSTEM.
OUR ECONOMY.
IF PARENTS CAN’T SAFELY SEND
THEIR CHILDREN TO SCHOOL MANY
OF THEM WON’T BE ABLE TO GO TO
WORK.
NOT EVERYONE CAN REMOTE WORK
THESE DAYS.
THERE ARE 100% RIGHT TO POINT
TO THIS WHICH IS WHY WE NEED
BOLD RESOURCING TO OUR STATES
AND OUR CITIES SO THEY CAN HAVE
ENOUGH TESTING AND FUND OUR
SCHOOLS ENOUGH TO OPEN THEM UP
SAFELY.
THIS IS ALL SO DEEPLY
INTERCONNECTED I AM HAPPY TO
SEE YOU TALKING ABOUT IT IN
THAT WAY.
WE WANT UNEMPLOYMENT TO GO DOWN.
IF WE WANT OUR ECONOMY TO
REBOUND WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO SAFELY OPEN UP OUR
SCHOOLS.
EVERYONE IS ON THE SAME PAGE
THERE.
OUR TEACHERS WANT TO GO BACK
SAFELY.
THEY DIDN’T SIGN UP TO STAY AT
HOME.
THEY JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT
THEY AREN’T GOING TO BE LOSING
THEIR LIVES.
>> Sandra: PUTTING A LOT OF
EMPHASIS ON THE SUPPLIES.
YOU TALK TO PEOPLE IN THE NEW
YORK AREA, PARENTS IN THE NEW
YORK AREA, THEY JUST WANT A
PLAN AND THEY WANT TO HEAR FROM
THE GOVERNOR.
A LOT OF THE SUPERINTENDENTS
SAY THERE IS A LACK OF
COMMUNICATION THERE.
THEY’VE WAITED A LONG TIME.
THERE IS STILL A LEVEL OF
UNCERTAINTY THAT IS DIFFICULT
TO DEAL WITH.
WE APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION,
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE A FINAL THOUGHT?